de plus en plus de gens cherchent à
restreindre ce kit appli le top écran la
sensibilisation à ce sujet de touche
surtout les jeunes
alors où tracer la ligne pour limiter
leur exposition aux écrans voici ce que
recommande la société canadienne de
pédiatrie aucun temps écran pour les
enfants âgés de moins de deux ans près
d'une heure par jour pour les 2 4 ans et
un maximum de deux heures par jour de
temps écran à des fins récréatives pour
les 5 à 17 ans g briceno dans toute la
discussion qu'on a en tant que société
sur la place des écrans dans le contexte
familial il me semble qu'on axe beaucoup
les choses sur l'enfant l'enfant
toujours l'enfant son rapport aux et
quand il part en eau tout ça c'est
effectivement une question très
intéressante parce que quand on fait de
la recherche sur ce sujet là un des
constats les plus étonnants et peut-être
le plus préoccupant vrai c'est de
réaliser qu effectivement beaucoup des
parents dont eux-mêmes une utilisation
pas toujours très modéré des écrans de
leurs appareils voire même parfois très
compulsif
je vous souhaite une étude tout à fait
étonnante en fait qu'ils étaient menés
en 2018 sur des familles canadiennes par
habile aux médias et qui rapporte que
les parents canadiens donc regarde plus
de télévision que leurs enfants
consomment significativement plus les
médias sociaux que leurs jeunes enfants
et consomme autant fait de jeu vidéo et
même de vidéos youtube
le paradoxe pour le parent moderne voit
aujourd'hui que c'est de devoir
justement enseigner à ces enfants de
saines habitudes
alors qu'il a lui même très souvent de
la difficulté en fait qu'il ait voire
même obsédé par ses propres écrans et
appareils
mais qu'est-ce que vous conseillez alors
aux parents qui nous écoutent pour les
parents qui ont des très jeunes enfants
ça commence par dessus et des routines
et des rituels autour des usages des
écrans ça commence par leur enseigner
que les écrans et les appareils
connectés c'est pas des jouets comme les
autres on demande la permission à papa
et maman
on détermine avec le parent combien de
temps on va passer à faire l'activité
sur la tablette ou à regarder une
émission par exemple et il faut
enseigner aux enfants même très très
jeune comment les éteindre
alors quand on a terminé l'émission est
ce que c'est toi qui étais la télévision
aussi maman et on apprend l'enfant a
intégré des habitudes très jeune
d'autorégulation dans l'eure
sage ensuite quand ils sont adolescents
et pluvieux faut s'intéresser
sincèrement en fait à ce que font nos
jeunes ont conduit au contenu lui me
contenu lui-même à leur usage à leur
rapport si on ne peut pas les banaliser
ne pas rire du fait que notre enfant
peut être triste parce que ya perdu un
ami sur facebook
la vérité c'est que ils ont des choses à
nous apprendre
ils peuvent nous aider à mieux
comprendre en fait cet univers dans
lequel nos enfants grandissent dans
lequel ils vont évoluer il ya absolument
pas de honte à demander à son enfant au
contraire de dire si j'ai entendu parler
justement de snap château de tik tok est
ce que tes amis ils utilisaient ce que
toi tu l'utilisent comment ça fonctionne
montre moi et donc ça prend une approche
de coéducation dans le numérique
alors parmi les la quantité incroyable
de métal déboulonner il y en a 1
principalement que le seul et unique
paramètre n'est pas le temps
d'exposition par jour aux échos
c'est un lieu commun sur lequel tout le
monde martèle beaucoup plus tout le
monde s'accroche beaucoup beaucoup de
parents me pose la question
oui mais combien de temps combien de
temps en fait toutes les études le
montrent que le temps écran peut pas
être le seul indicateur pour nous
permettre d'évaluer le bien-être où la
relation entre l'usagé des écrans fait
et le bien-être des enfants
ça prend une ovation évaluation globale
donc si notre adolescent on trouve
qu'ils passent trop de temps sur les
jeux vidéo mais que par ailleurs il dort
bien et mange bien y réussit bien à
l'école des amis c'est pas
nécessairement un problème
en outre les chercheurs en fait cherche
à imposer aussi qu'on évalue non
seulement le temps écran mais surtout la
qualité des contenus auxquels nos
enfants sont exposés un enfant qui
laissait tout seul naviguer sur youtube
regarder des vidéos qui sont pas
adaptées à son âge pendant 15 minutes
c'est pire qu'un enfant qui passe
quarante cinq minutes à jouer sur une
tablette encore socialisant avec son
parent à faire des casse tête
et donc si ça notre rôle de parent c'est
de préparer en fait nos enfants pour cet
avenir là et pour le monde de demain à
être des citoyens numériques à part
entière
[Musique]